[Musique]
le calme sous l'équateur est souvent
trompeurs il est même plutôt
annonciateur d'événements
extraordinaires
j -1
enfin le moment pour elle de sortir de
son hangar
54 mètres de haut pour 750 tonnes
cette drôle de créature qui part se
promener au dessus des arbres de la
savane n'a rien d'exotique ici c'est la
fusée ariane 5
posé sur des rails tractée par un camion
elle va rejoindre son aire de lancement
à trois kilomètres de là sur la base de
kourou en guyane
demain elle doit décoller pour mettre en
orbite deux satellites l'un est
américain l'autre appartient à des
indonésiens ces derniers ont parcouru la
moitié de la planète pour venir ici et
ils sont extrêmement ému
accès
je suis très excité
vraiment je suis très heureuse
quant à lui on peut voir notre satellite
ici et demain on espère bien que
lancement sera un grand succès
monsieur siam dirige l'une des plus
grande banque d'indonésie il a 53
millions de clients et il a besoin de
son satellite pour sécuriser ses
échanges avec eux pour ça il n'a pas
hésité à investir plus de 200 millions
d'euros
nous sommes la première et la seule
banque au monde à disposer de notre
propre satellite
nous espérons être beaucoup plus
performant à l'ère de la banque
numérique
depuis vingt ans des dizaines de pays
viennent en guyane lancer leurs
satellites consacrant ariane 5 est cool
comme les champions du monde des tirs de
satellites commerciaux
loin devant les américains les russes ou
les chinois
l'aboutissement d'une folle aventure
initiée il ya plus de 50 ans
pour partir à la conquête de l'espace
la france a choisi l'un de ses
territoires les plus éloignés
la guyane
à 7000 km de paris
sur le continent sud américain
cette région d'amazonie un immense
avantage au plus près de l'équateur elle
occupe une position idéale pour lancer
des fusées
le centre spatial de kourou emploie
aujourd'hui plus de 1500 personnes
ingénieurs techniciens mais également en
pompier ou légionnaires qui font de ce
site civil le plus protégé de france
ils sont des centaines chaque année à
abandonner la métropole pour venir
travailler au coeur du département le
plus sauvage de france avec sa forêt
vierge et ses animaux dangereux
mais avec également ses dizaines de
kilomètres de plage
dans quelques jours l'envol d'ariane-5
marquera l'apothéose de deux mois de
travail pour les équipes du centre
spatial
conçu en europe les éléments du lanceur
sont arrivés par bateau dans ces
immenses containers
ils ont été ensuite assemblés sur place
à kourou avec d'infinies précautions
puis les deux satellites ont été
préparés sous atmosphère confinée et
placé bien à l'abri sous la coiffe de la
fusée
si tout va bien ariane 5 réussir à
bientôt sa 72e mise en orbite
successives
un record inégalé à ce jour
[Musique]
quitter la métropole pour venir
travailler au centre spatial de kourou
c'est changer radicalement de vie et de
climat
[Musique]
originaire du sud ouest pierre
chadouteau a posé ses valises sous
l'équateur il y a un an son premier choc
ici a été thermique en guyane la
température avoisine les 30 degrés toute
l'année et l'humidité y est de 95%
qui m'a difficile mais aussi habituer un
petit peu au début qu'on sème là la
chambre climatisée
on sort nous la porte bout de suite
l'humidité petit peu la moiteur on te
dit ça y est j'ai tout fait depuis
c'est parti pour la journée
ce qui a amené pierre en guyane c'est le
rêve de beaucoup d'enfants
faire décoller des fusées
une consécration pour cet ingénieur de
59 ans qui a fait l'essentiel de sa
carrière au centre national d'études
spatiales de toulouse pour cela il est
reparti à zéro de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
de valises
fournissent en arrive là mais on va
fournir le mobilier bon alors c'est
lorsqu'il faut quoi
c'est vrai que je pourrai mais des
tableaux des trucs question déco c'est
un petit peu même minimaliste
arriver avec des contes des conteneurs
des ménages carrément
pour vivre sa passion pierre a dû
consentir à quelques sacrifices
occupait ce logement un peu spartiate et
surtout laissé en métropole sa compagne
et ses deux fils qui pour le soutenir
dans son aventure lui envoie
régulièrement des petits mots tu vois
sur il est
sympa et vend un petit coeur c'est le
papa on coucou de toulouse j'espère que
tu vois bien guyane je t'aime ennemis
avec un magnifique
mais l'essentiel de son temps
l'ingénieur le passe à quelques
kilomètres de là
direction le centre spatial
dans six jours ariane 5 doit décoller
pour la 230e fois
un vol au cours duquel pierre va jouer
l'un des tout premiers rôles au coeur
d'un lieu mythique
le centre de contrôle des fusées pierre
y occupe un fauteuil très convoité celui
de directeur des opérations
le ddo en jargon spatiale c'est lui qui
procédera au compte à rebours final mais
avant d'en arriver là il va falloir
débloquer des centaines de verrous de
sécurité
car étonnamment l'ordinateur à bord
d'ariane 5 est programmé pour ne jamais
décoller tant qu'on ne l'a pas convaincu
qu'il n'y a aucun danger pour qu'un
lancement sort ici il faut qu' il ya
énormément d'événements qui se passe
bien les uns ou en eau en parallèle où
les uns derrière les autres et en fait
le système est fait pour que le lanceur
ne parte pas et on est là pour
déverrouiller toutes ces étapes pour
s'assurer que effectivement à partir
assister d'ingénieurs au titre parfois
incompréhensibles pour le commun des
mortels
pierre va aujourd'hui simuler le
prochain lancement
l'objectif c'est que tous ses voyants
restent au vert jusqu'à l'heure h tout
doit être optimale de la météo jusqu au
trafic car pour arriver en orbite le
chemin d'une fusée ressemble à une
autoroute il peut y avoir des bouchons
et même des carambolages
avant de faire un lancement on s'assure
qu'on n'a pas de critères de collision
avec la station spatiale internationale
c'est mieux voilà donc dans notre oui
c'est mieux pour nous
donc on n'est pas en mode missile
donc
et là on vient d'avoir la confirmation
qu effectivement notre parole notre
fenêtre de lancement on peut y aller au
moins sur ce critère là on est en hiver
rsv de ddo
pour l'étape des moyens s'il te plaît
ok je remercie et des modems
annoncé que tous les moyens mesures sont
verts ok on est bien parti mais
contrairement à ce que pense pierre
cette répétition générale ne va pas être
de tout repos à quelques minutes du
lancement fictifs les ordinateurs du
centre de contrôle vont simuler un
incident
rouge
rouge mesure
oui oui j'en ai donc on a un problème
sur la synchro jupiter 1 on a beau être
dans un exercice pierre doit réagir
comme en plein lancement au moindre
voyant rouge le compte à rebours est
immédiatement stoppés à tous de ddo
l'arrêt du décompte suite par un rouge
télémesure
dans la salle aucun affolement ce
lancement fictif sert aussi à tester le
sang froid des ingénieurs face à un
imprévu
réunis en cellule de crise loin de notre
caméra ils vont en quelques minutes
identifiez l'incident le résoudre
et finalement relancé le compte à
rebours
[Applaudissements]
on est en partie vidéo pour cm les deux
charges utiles sont prêtes à repartir
sans préavis
pierre est désormais aussi concentré que
s'il s'agissait du véritable lancement
top h0 moins une minute
c'est arrivé vite un camp sa dépouille
le promu a tous deux les déos attention
pour le décompte final dix neuf huit
sept
six cinq
quatre
3 2
tom
à l'image des zapper décollage
la simulation est un succès
séparation du satellite britannique
le vrai décollage dans quelques jours
sera une autre affaire
cigare
[Rires]
comme pierre ils sont neuf mille à
travailler directement ou indirectement
pour le centre spatial soit le tiers de
la population de kourou
mais la ville ne vit pas uniquement au
rythme des lancements de fusées
entre océan fleuve et forêt amazonienne
elle offre bien des surprises
on y rencontre par exemple de drôles
d'oiseaux
[Musique]
comme lionel collado
avec son look d'aventurier
il a épousé l'amazone il n'y a plus de
20 ans
après quelques années à travailler au
centre spatial lionel est devenu guide
touristique
en ce jour de marché il a des emplettes
à faire pour les clients qu'il s'apprête
à emmener à l' aventure ce week-end
non d'abord pour bien les motiver
les soirs à laval 2 1
eh ben ils parlent et pousser les fruits
d'un palmier donc c'est très riche et
très bon c'est un peu le goût
un mélange subtil mélange entre la
châtaigne et le coeur d'artichaut on va
dire les maracuja et s'est dit si ça
pousse vraiment bien la mangue et tu
manges tu en manges tu jettes ton monte
on tonton noyau ça y est il ya un manque
et qui va sortir un peu partout des
manguiers
en ville tout le monde connaît lionel
pourtant il en est qui s'étonne encore
de son mode de vie très singulier où
qu'ils aillent quel que soit le temps le
guide est marester pieds nus
non seulement c'est vrai d'ailleurs de
prendre des trucs dans les pieds bah ça
m'arrive ailleurs le jour je me suis dit
voilà avec un tesson de bouteille la ham
c'est un tel plaisir de sentir un coup
le sable chaud un coup tu sens l'herbe
humide les troncs sec et trop mouillé le
sable la terre la terre sèche à terre
mouillée c'est bon c'est un massage
permanent ce jour-là pour les courses
lionel et son assistante ont vu grand
ils attendent pas moins d'une quinzaine
de clients pour le week end alors le
chou
la papaye
s'appelle seulement concombres
le moment ou jamais
là où lionel s'apprête à partir il n'y a
aucune route
le seul moyen de rejoindre l'amazonie
c'est par le fleuve cours ou en pirogue
les gens prochain canopée venez par ici
s'il vous plaît
lionel et son équipe en mène ce matin
leurs clients dans un coin reculé de la
forêt
un lieu qui est le territoire de
nombreux animaux sauvages entre serpent
jaguar caïmans et moustiques julie ne
sais pas ce qui l'inquiète le plus cette
jeune kiné est arrivé de métropole il y
a tout juste une semaine
on a tous pris ces bons crème
pas dormi
pourquoi
tout ce qu'on entend ça fait peur après
quand on en parle directement avec les
gens d'ici ça va
l'impressionnant
et
royal
[Musique]
c'est parti pour un voyage en pirogue
qui va durer près de trois heures
demain
très vite l'inquiétude se transforme en
fascination devant le décor enchanteur
de cette forêt primaire qui bordent
chaque méandres du fleuve couru
bon
ce trajet lionel l'empreinte deux à
trois fois par semaine pour aller
travailler sans jamais s'en lasser
lui qui depuis son adolescence a
toujours rêvé de l'amazonie
[Musique]
j'ai choisi mon camp
fois quand il
[Musique]
me rappelle mes
pour certains passagers ce week end a
une saveur particulière
c'est le cas d'aline et de sa famille
son mari laurent ingénieur au centre
spatial termine son contrat à la fin du
mois ils sont venus s'offrir un baroud
d'honneur
chercher
bien mémorable
on s'en va dans trois semaines en
rentrant m
mais
- est venu
une image
nature
c'est impensable
attention vos programmes sur les
passants et à kamina
les voici arrivés sur le domaine de
lionel
[Musique]
de grand carbet des maisons
traditionnelle amérindienne perchées
dans les arbres
et reliées entre elles par des ponts de
singe
là
[Musique]
c'est lionel qui a bâti tout cela de ses
propres mains
et il a prévu pour ses invités un week
end à couper le souffle
au même moment au centre spatial le pas
de tir et ses quatre gigantesques
paratonnerre s'apprête à accueillir
ariane 5 au royaume de l'hyper
technologies on n'a pas encore trouvé
mieux qu'un bon vieux balai pour dégager
les rails sur lesquels la fusée va
circuler pour l'heure celle ci est
encore à l'abri dans ce bâtiment de 90
mètres de haut à l'horizon
c'est le territoire des ingénieurs
d'arianespace
comme lauren vernis et frédéric faquins
ils ont ici une lourde responsabilité
car derrière ce géant de 54 mètres de
haut il y à des enjeux financiers
astronomiques
entre le prix des satellites et de prix
du lanceur et le prix du service de
lancement effectivement c'est des
centaines de millions d'actes et ça
dépend des charges utiles de clients via
les satellites qui sont des satellites
commerciaux qui sont les stats et du
standard qui coule ou un peu moins cher
mais on met d'un d'une gamme de 203,5
millions d'euros pour le projet des
satellites de type scientifique pourrait
coûter un milliard de milliards d'euros
voire plus donc on voit bien la miss et
les missions à plusieurs milliards
d'euros et là effectivement à une
certaine pression sur les épaules
ne cache pas qu on n'y passe pas toutes
les secondes parce qu'autrement
à seulement 42 ans frédéric est déjà un
vétéran de l'aventuré spatiale
avec 121 lancement à son actif il
connaît par coeur chaque pièce d'ariane
5 comme ce moteur vulcain qui va devoir
assurer la poussée au décollage
sur cette fusée
c'est lui l'ingénieur en chef
[Musique]
donc on a une belle vue sur le lanceur
donc ce n'est pas entièrement découvert
parce qu'il ya un temps des plateformes
d'accès parce que la préparation ne
l'entendait pas qu'on termine et on
arrive au bout les dernières
préparations de finale seront pour un
prolo nuit donc on a quatre jours du
lancement
vu l'enjeu la fusée va faire l'objet de
centaines de contrôles tout est ultra
réglementée bonjour
[Musique]
voila ça a été fermé 1
vérifier à l'aide d'un tournevis que les
quatre clapet de surpression départ jobs
sont en position fermée
le moindre coup de tournevis fait
l'objet d'une procédure écrite et il est
contrôlé en temps réel par un
superviseur
et
ok
au delà du coût faramineux de cette
fusée cette obsession du contrôle est
aussi guidés par des enjeux de sécurité
ouais
merci à eux
avec les tonnes de poudre et de produits
chimiques qu'elle contient ariane 5
pourrait se transformer en bombe alors
au moindre doute les ingénieurs
préfèrent carrément reporter un
lancement c'est ce qui va arriver avec
ce vol alors que nous sommes
théoriquement à j moins quatre le tir va
être repoussé à trois reprises et
reprogrammée dix jours plus tard
[Musique]
des incidents qui oblige à tout annuler
il peut s'en produire à tout moment à
kourou
pour veiller sur le centre spatial les
ingénieurs s'en remettent à leur ange
gardien des pompiers qui viennent
d'autres cieux ceux de paris on les voit
à l'entraînement sous l'oeil attentif de
leur chef le capitaine laurent oignons
c'est mon égard elle tenu à léger
pour un season tranquillement
les pompiers de paris à 7000 kilomètres
de la capitale cela peut surprendre mais
pour intervenir sur ce site hautement
sensible il fallait des pompiers
professionnels et rompu aux risques
industriels
pompiers de paris a courroucé quand même
pas banal on a la chance de pouvoir être
ici alors on se prépare avant puisque
tous les gens qui viennent ici ont des
formations sur les risques chimiques et
radiologiques et puis après il faut
s'adapter au monde du spatial qui est
complètement différent
le détachement du capitaine onillon
compte 80 hommes pour avoir le droit de
venir ici tous ont dû afficher minimum 5
ans d'états de service
à l'image du sergent chef arnaud bobier
ce matin le chef bobier va diriger un
exercice qui ne pourrait se passer nulle
part ailleurs en france
tu avances
donc voilà on est arrivé
avec ses hommes il va simuler une fuite
de carburant pour satellites
donc là les gars moi je viens d'avoir la
sauvegarde apparemment ça serait de
l'hydrazine c'est ok allez on s'équipe
donc là on va équiper les personnels de
l'appareil respiratoire isolant
l'hydrazine est un carburant spatiale
explosif est extrêmement toxique en
ligne a lancé homme pourrait faire un
den pulmonaire est même tombé dans le
coma le risque il existe alors il est
maîtrisé
il est vraiment pris en compte mais y'a
pas le risque zéro n'existant pas on
doit se préparer à ce genre de choses
donc il ya forcément un peu de stress
quand on va faire une une détection sur
ce genre de produit parce que les
produits qu'on met dans les carburants
des satellites sont quand même des
produits qui sont hautement inflammables
et pour certains explosifs si jamais
voilà s'il ya quand même un risque
existe qu'au fond en est conscient vous
faites bien de détection avec l'appareil
et le hand rigueur et si jamais il ya
quelque chose par radio vous transmettez
le relevé que vous avez sur ppr et
d'accor
allaitent leurs
protégés par leurs combinaisons étanches
les pompiers vont intervenir sur le
bâtiment où sont remplies les réservoirs
des satellites
avec leurs instruments de mesure ils
vont rechercher une éventuelle fuite de
produits chimiques
bien
qu'un peu
0 0
je
allez-y allez-vous d équipe et les gars
fin de l'exercice
et retour vers la caserne
pour les pompiers
c'est l'heure du sport
durant leur tour de garde ils ont deux
séances obligatoires par jour même dans
la moiteur guyanaise
et tant pis s'il transpire avant même le
début de l'exercice
[Musique]
à l'image d'arnaud bobier tous étaient
volontaires ils ont signé pour quatre
ans à kourou pour eux la guyane est à la
fois une aventure professionnelle et
humaine
on se retrouve dans un monde qu'on ne
connaît pas avec des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas donc automatiquement les
liens vont se faire tout de suite avec
nos collègues pompiers de collègues de
travail du moins et les familles après
apprennent à se connaître et ça crée des
liens qui sont même très fort peut-être
même plus fort qu'en métropole ces
quatre années que l'on vit ensemble
c'est un petit peu notre deuxième
famille qui est
pour nous et ces liens vivre sous
l'équateur offre quelques avantages
comme celui de pouvoir profiter de la
douceur des plages de kourou situé à
deux pas de chez arnaud et où ils
peuvent venir quand il n'est pas de
garde
il les retrouve souvent quelques-uns de
ses collègues
comme grégory et clément les trois
pompiers qui ne se connaissaient pas
avant de quitter paris sont devenus très
amis et c'est ensemble qu'ils savourent
leur chance d'être ici
je pense que là qui nous ont envie ouais
y en a qui nous envient surtout la
famille quand on leur montre sur sur les
photographies sur skype on leur montre
en direct que la piscine à côté les
cocotiers ouais ça c'est
ouais c'est ça c'est paradisiaque
arnaud est arrivé accompagné de sa femme
et de ses petites filles
ce projet tous en rêvait ne serait ce
que pour le soleil et les joies de la
plage
et même au bout d'un an la guyane leur
réserve encore des surprises
comme une pêche miraculeuse
un poisson de 5 kilos qu émerge tout
seul de l'eau
[Rires]
[Musique]
fatma les pouces d'arnaud s'est elle
aussi parfaitement acclimatés à cette
nouvelle vie même si toute la famille
sait déjà que l' aventure aura une fin
j'ai retrouvé du travail
assez facilement la vie s'il me plaît
beaucoup de belles découvertes que ce
soit la nature après nous on aime bien
tout ce qui est le calme la nature les
animaux
[Musique]
certes celui qui aime la ville ici ça
sera plus compliqué pour lui je pense
on n'oublie pas ce qu'on est ce qu'on
faisait en métropole on a on a mis une
parenthèse on a fait ce top plutôt pause
et dans quatre ans on pense qu'on
repartira quoi mais oui c'est une belle
parenthèse par contre pour les corps
il est vrai que pour les expatriés en
guyane les occasions de faire des
parenthèses enchantées ne se limite pas
qu'à la plage
dans la forêt équatoriale nos touristes
de l'amazone y sont prêts à prendre leur
envol
là tu veux attirer sur ton t-shirt
derrière aline julie et les autres vont
passer l'après-midi dans les arbres
allez un premier volontaire pour partir
en tyrolienne un une
lionel va les emmener jusqu'à la canopée
mais après cette petite descente en
tyrolienne en guise de hors d'oeuvre
certains se demandent encore ce que la
forêt va leur réserver
dans les arbres est cool
mais voilà encore un peu le stress quand
même parce que tu vois on
a line a raison de se faire du souci car
arrivé un peu plus loin les choses se
corsent
ils vont devoir grimper à la force des
jambes
[Musique]
bat au rythme d'un alpiniste tupou
sortait jamais tu mets un coup de bassin
vers le holà
l'objectif c'est cette plateforme à 36
mètres du sol
[Musique]
du haut de ses 9 ans léandre le fils
d'aline va avaler la montée en un rien
de temps pour découvrir une vue
imprenable sur l'amazonie
savoir c'est l'arbre le plus grand de
lagardère
pas trop fatigué bon ça suffit c'est
physique tu trouves
avait vite fait un petit bout d'homme
quand même et dix minutes c'est physique
en bas certains sont encore à se faire
violence voilà
petite appréhension quand même d'en
vivre trois semaines de hausse je pense
que
[Musique]
mais au delà de l'altitude la chaleur et
l'humidité à plus de 95% ne facilite pas
la tâche des grimpeurs
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi
je la même température que leurs hommes
fallait que je monte je voulais par des
centres
n'ont pas spécialement mais bon quand tu
es à 15 m 2 où tu reviendras tu veux je
vais continuer à monter
pour lionel qui pratiquer l'alpinisme
depuis l'enfance la montée est une
simple formalité
[Musique]
cet observatoire au milieu des arbres il
a également bâti lui même
c'est son havre de paix d'où il a même
une vue imprenable sur les décollage de
la fusée ariane
[Musique]
koné dit si pardon il y avait décollé
d'istres oui oui oui
il ya des fois il ya eu une ariane 5
alors la traînée blanche qui monte est
déformée par des vents dans un sens ici
et par des vents de l'autre et la fumée
former un gros cinq comme ça dans le
ciel vous avez la fumée qui monte est à
vingrau 5 et après qui continuer comme
ça
pour sa première fois dans la forêt
julie a totalement évacué son
appréhension avant le départ
s'est plaint de
la dimension qui se mélange entre la
peur et l'excitation sentiment de
liberté on peut dépasser ses peurs
[Musique]
mais il lui reste une dernière épreuve
une descente en rappel à la nuit
tombante
c'est impossible vraiment vraiment
c'est pas du tout petit nom
est impossible que ça lâche
céder notre chaise qui achètent
mais notre lui c'est le seul mec et
sécurité après le cabestan n'est pas de
sécurit bon mais c'est bon c'est arrivé
c'est à toi
à l'arrivée nos aventuriers du jour
seront récompensés de leurs efforts
lionel leur a réservé une soirée haute
en couleurs locales
m 2
vignal
[Musique]
de quoi finir en beauté ce week-end dans
les arbres
c'est des journées comme aujourd'hui on
en prend quand même plein les yeux aux
là on dit quand même c'est un décor
qu'on voit pas partout donc ses flèches
pas
paraître un peu fade la métropole à côté
non
cvs crainte c'est mes craintes et les
craintes du début du retour en métropole
c'est vrai que ça m'a choqué
on s'habitue à tout on était très
inquiet de venir en guyane
on s'adaptera
[Musique]
mais avant le retour en métropole ils
ont encore un dernier grand événement à
vivre
au centre spatial le jour j approche
pour frédéric l'ingénieur d'arianespace
la porte du gigantesque hangar
d'assemblage a été ouverte signe que le
lancement est désormais tout proche
[Musique]
oui
depuis cette plateforme à plus de 40
mètres du sol frédéric profite d'un
instant privilégié avant de reprendre
les opérations techniques
fois que la porte est ouverte en des
magnifiques paysages sur sur la forêt
est juste là sur le coin en vo la zone
de lancement danse nôtres ça va être
l'objectif du jour
l'objectif de la de la matinée c'est
c'est d'amener le lanceur et la table
ronde au lancement au bout la barre face
de moi
pour les ingénieurs comme lui la fusée
ariane n'est pas qu'une histoire de
prouesse technologique
un lancement est également chargée en
émotions comme en témoigne un rituel qui
a été instauré avant chaque vol
juste avant le lancement pendant la
préparation finale des clients vient de
signer leur logo et met un petit mot de
sympathie à la fois aux lanceurs mais
aussi et surtout à leurs satellites vers
se fait en général un bon courage et bon
vol c'est un moment qui est très
attendue par les clients tout cas ils
aiment bien venir et
inscrire quelque chose se dire aussi que
peut-être qu'ils vont envoyer quelque
chose une perte de 2 m dans l'espace
d'un côté de ça dans leur club
effectivement c'est c'est devenu une
forme de tradition un petit rituel
ce soir
engendre le lancement en six ans attaché
un petit peu au lanceur thème on a passé
un petit peu de temps on a mis beaucoup
de notre énergie donc
forcément comme toute chose lorsqu'on
met beaucoup d'énergie sur quelque chose
on commence à s'y attacher donc après et
on sait que dans 2 jours sera plus là
et donc après on aura un peu le baby
blues
ça a duré un jour et puis après ça
passera on s'attaquera une nouvelle
nouvelle préparation de lancement
mais pas le temps de s'émerveiller
désormais la fusée est à découvert et
nous sommes dans la phase la plus
sensible de la campagne de lancement
c'est au tour de l'armée d'entrer en
action
en france aucun site civil n'est aussi
sécurisé que le centre spatial
400 hommes sur la pour parer à toute
menace terroriste ou tentatives
d'espionnage parmi eux un régiment de la
légion étrangère
surveillance aérienne
sécurisation des zones côtières
déploiement de missiles sol-air dernière
génération
ainsi que des patrouilles par tous les
moyens de transport possibles
en quad
mais également en kayak à travers la
mangrove une démonstration de force
deux jours
comme de nuit
personne ne doit pouvoir approcher de la
fusée qui se trouve maintenant sur son
pas de tir
[Musique]
au centre de contrôle la tension monte à
quelques heures du lancement
après trois reports de tir en dix jours
tout le monde espère que cette fois sera
la bonne
pour pierre le directeur des opérations
cela paraît bien engagée
tous les voyants sont au vert
les banquiers indonésien eux sont
fébriles leur patron monsieur siam ne
tient plus en place comme un futur père
au moment de l'accouchement il
s'inquiète pour son bébé son satellite à
plus de 200 millions d'euros
on
se sent tout petit et très impatients
sur son pas de tir ariane 5 semble enfin
prêt à prendre son envol
un spectacle que nos touristes de la
forêt équatoriale
aline laurent et leurs enfants ne
voudrait rater pour rien au monde
la veille ils se sont déplacés pour rien
c'est leur dernière chance d'assister au
lancement avant de rentrer en métropole
comme des dizaines d'autres curieux ils
se sont positionnés en haut du mont
carapa un observatoire naturel à une
quinzaine de kilomètres du pas de tir
on voit bien quand
ça va être sympa
l'énergie
la force qui
est développé pour arriver à avoir la
fusée décoller je trouve que là ça prend
ça prend une dimension
c'est vraiment toute particulière les
hélicoptères
l'armée qui patrouillent pour sécuriser
la zone un signe révélateur pour aline
celui du décollage imminent
[Musique]
mais génial il même pas nous coucou
maintenant
[Rires]
mais au même moment on n'en mène pas si
large au centre de contrôle pierre est
obligé de suspendre le compte à rebours
à quelques minutes à peine du lancement
à tous de ddo rédu des comptes twitter
ensemble de lancement de tous les moyens
restent prêts pour la reprise de la
chronologie à hii 0 - sept minutes en
cas de retour au vert
tout en haut de l'écran à gauche de
voyants ont viré au rouge les ingénieurs
n'ont qu'une fenêtre de tir de 50
minutes pour réaliser le lancement il
leur faut d'urgence élucider l'origine
de la laërt sinon la fusée restera cloué
au sol une fois de plus
les clients indonésiens accuse le coup
tandis que sur le mont cas rappaz
l'information vient tout juste d'être
diffusé dans les haut parleurs
rouge ensemble de lancement non
conformes
à ces la fusée qui les fuit
qui dit je veux pas pas prête
il va falloir de longues minutes aux
ingénieurs pour tous revérifier et
finalement levé les doutes
alors que tout le monde commence à
anticiper un nouveau report de tir in
extremis le message retenti dans la
station
à tous de l'été au retour au vert de
l'ensemble de lancement
attention pour la reprise de prologis
début de la séquence finale lanceur
[Musique]
à 0
nous voyons les
sur les terrasses d'observation pour
assister au lancement
juste au coucher du soleil ici à kourou
riche de huit mètres
vingt quatre bons
[Musique]
l'allumage des apps et décollages
pas m aborde sur
pour les banquiers indonésien c'est la
délivrance
leurs satellites fils enfin vers
l'espace
connaissez vous
bien mais toulon
la fin
à ce moment précis la fusée est
entièrement autonome ce sont ces
ordinateurs de bord hyper puissants
qu'ils vont réaliser seule la séparation
des différents éléments
jusqu'à la mise en orbite des deux
satellites
45 minutes plus tard
les indonésiens peuvent enfin laisser
éclater leur joie
[Musique]
pas du tout
on est les veinards
on a trop de la chambre
non mais regarde ce qui est magnifique
il fait encore jour le soleil est encore
là on l'a vu sur quasiment toute sa
trajectoire fait presque le plus beau
lancement
à lille laurent et leurs enfants vont
pouvoir rentrer en métropole des étoiles
plein les yeux
au centre de contrôle les ingénieurs
seront restés tendus jusqu'à la dernière
minute
pour pierre c'est la libération ariane 5
est parti deux minutes avant que la
fenêtre de tir ne se referme
[Musique]
[Rires]
extraordinaire
paupières c'était le dernier lancement
en tant que directeur des opérations
c'était
fini pour moi
je suis derrière et que je regarde
il va bientôt intégrer la direction du
centre spatial
[Rires]
[Musique]
quant au prochain lancement d'ariane il
est déjà programmée pour dans deux mois
[Applaudissements]